today's workout is a heat cardio app
blaster this workout challenge is in
partnership with circa dna which is
currently the world's most comprehensive
dna test so this one test can provide
you with over 500 reports since learning
more about my own sports profile which
is high endurance medium power and low
strength i've adapted my training to
match my sports profile and honestly
i've seen better results and also
quicker improvements in my own training
so today i've designed this workout to
combine explosive movements with no rest
in between and also to work on our
cardio this workout is going to help you
to touch lots of calories to build a
strong and firm abs and also to increase
your power and endurance ability for
those of you who are curious and
interested to discover your own sports
profile whether you're more dominant
towards strength power or endurance then
do check out circle dna the link will be
in my description box below be sure to
use the promo code joanna at checkout to
get one kit for 35 off two to three kids
for 40 off and four or more kids for 50
off so this is applicable to any circle
dna kit you purchase and the offer is
only limited to the first 100 kids sold
so be sure to share this information
with your family and friends remember
all you need is only one test for a
lifetime because your genetics will not
change so this is an investment for your
own health journey and with all the
information you have you'll be able to
better plan your training as well as
diet and progress quicker in your
fitness goal so let's get started with
today's challenge
[Music]
are we ready for this challenge so each
workout will only be for 30 seconds long
and we want to move on to the next
workout without any breaks in between so
it's going to be back to back with a
total of three circuits this workout
will have a lot of explosive movement so
let's get your energy up let's start
with a quick warm-up let's just twist
the opposite side
warming up on your core as well as your
total body so drive your knees up to
reach your
elbows
okay twist
and twist now just jog on the spot
shake your arms out relax your shoulders
loosen up all the joints
good job and just breathe
and now let's get down on to the floor
for our first workout okay the first
workout is going to be full crunches
right so place your hands
just by your side legs up crunch up
reach and
try to reach for your ankles tap
release
and straight
legs
good job
remember to breathe out
as you crunch
up
lift your shoulders
off the floor
very nice only
30 seconds and
get
back
up now push yourself up
no rest in and out squat tap down
reach
and tap
so this
will work on your cardio okay so we're
alternating between abs and cardio tap
reach
and good job
tap
step one push your knees out
land softly one more and now let's get
back down okay flatter kicks lie back
down push yourself up now just point and
give me flatter kicks so brace your core
left and right up and down remember to
just support your upper body okay all
the work should be on your lower abs
breathe
good job i can already feel my abs on
fire
last few more
and now drop
push yourself back up now step at the
edge of your mat jump forward
run back
jump all the way forward
run back
forward
back
forward
and back towards you
lots of explosive movement
back
good job
step back
jump forward
one more
and now
lie straight back on to the ground back
to the first workout full crunches up
reach
extend
reach
and extend
can you feel your heart rate can you
feel your heart pumping
that's what we want
we want to work on our endurance
our power
and to really
tone the mid section
good job and now get up push yourself up
and up in and out squat tap down
tap
and reach
push
good job
tap
remember to pace your workout taste your
movement and pace your breathing
good
reach tap
low squat
keep going
that's one more
and back down
oh my gosh okay just support the upper
body
flat the kicks okay up
ready let's go
okay so breathing
small movement
yet extremely effective
focus
on your lower abs
breathe
that's five more seconds
four
three
two
one drop and now let's get back up
all right are we ready at the edge of a
mat
jump forward
run back
jump forward
jump forward and run back
good job
keep going
as far forward as you can
challenge
your explosive power
let's go
hop
that's one more
forward
run
and break okay take a shot 40 seconds
break and we want to move into the
second circuit if you want to drink some
water keep yourself hydrated okay
[Music]
second circuit four minutes long as well
so the first workout is going to be
v-tucks
start on your butt place your arms
behind just to support your body and
keep both legs straight and
just lift them up
in to
the shape of a v okay
up
and tuck it in
good job nice and controlled
up and down
up and down
good
i can see my legs shaking that is good
my core is on fire
nice and controlled movement do not drop
your heels right now one more
and down okay let's get into mountain
climbers okay so high plank
ready let's run
drive your knees in towards your chest
press into the ground
bring your heart rate back up
and keep
running up the hill
keep going
up
up up
good job high energy
let's go we want to torch lots of
calories and really work on your cardio
endurance good back down
now
reverse
let's get into rainbow lake races okay
so same thing just like v-tucks now just
move side to side so imagine that's a
line directly in front of you and you
want to shift your weight to the left
and to the right
good job
out
and out
one more
and
into a plank this time plank touch okay
so high plank tuck both legs in out in
out and in
good job
so remember
to really feel the crunch on your abs
drive your knees in towards your chest
only 30 seconds guys you're almost there
and we want to repeat the entire circuit
once more
push it out
in
and back
okay
i told you
no rest quick change okay
let's go support the upper body point
both toes together
detox
up
up good job
if this is getting too tough what you
can do is change it into a knee
tuck okay drive your knee in and out
good job last few more in and out
in
change
high plank
straight into a
mountain climber let's go running up the
hill
i know the hill is getting steep but
we're strong so we're going to finish
right at the top
let's go
keep going
feel your hybrid pumping feel your
hungry going up
let's climb last five seconds
push push push
bring your knees in towards your chest
good job now back into the sitting
position
rainbow leg raises okay so support your
upper body
let's start from the left to the right
and
imagine you're drawing a rainbow
yes while working on your obliques
left and right
left and right
good job
strong car
strong legs keep going last one more
and back into a plank all right this
time let's end with plank tucks high
plank
both legs drive your knees in together
and as you push back
keep up flat back okay so do not dip
your hips or arch your lower back keep
going push in
and out
a few more
and
ring
oh my gosh okay
two
circuits down all right
and this final circuit i want you to
give me all your energy
are you still with me okay
final second
let's go only four minutes workout life
flat down the first workout it's going
to be a star crunch okay so spread your
arms out by your side we want to reach
for the opposite
side
crunch
and
reach
twist
really reach as far as you can
and
twist
good job lifting your shoulders
off
the floor
and breathe out
as you crunch up every time you crunch
that's when
you breathe out
a few more one more
and get straight back up into standing
side to side shuffle let's go tap
tap
tap
tap
good job shuffle to the left and to the
right tap
tap
tap
tap good job keep going
and straight back
on to the ground okay reach low tap low
let's get back down all right lie down
bicycle crunches
good job
straight legs
twist
and
reach
keep it going keep it moving
try to reach
your elbow to the opposite direction
and get back
up
jumping jacks okay let's go
my hair is a mess
my energy is high
stay with me
almost two minutes down
two minutes to go
out and in
you are strong team you are strong i
want you to end this 15-minute challenge
strong
okay get back down
star crunches let's lie down
spread your legs spread your arms
reach
good job twist
as high as you can as far as you can
reach for the stars
oh yes
grab the star
very good you're almost at the end of
your workout now push yourself
up okay let's go side to side shuffle oh
my gosh let's go shuffle
and tap
working on your agility let's see how
quickly can you shift from one position
to the next
shift go
keep going
speed it up
let's go
let's go five seconds push it do the
burn on your thighs
that's two more
and oh
oh my gosh
back down
oh final one minute
oh
let's go bicycle crunches okay legs up
twist
and go
my heart rate is crazy
it is at its peak right now i am not
stopping and you're not stopping as well
keep going
five more seconds
reach
reach
reach
ah
final 30 seconds to celebrate
oh my gosh
victory
jumping
jacks
let's go
i know you got this 15 seconds left
we're at the finishing line we're gonna
reach
the finishing line in 10 seconds
keep going
five
four
three
two
one
ah
very very
very bad okay
catch your breath
i've completed this workout together
with you
i know how you're feeling
i'm out of breath
my heart rate is at
170 bpm i'm feeling really good i'm
feeling really strong and that's how i
want you to feel at the end of this
challenge as well okay if you say hey
joanna i want more then feel free to
repeat this challenge once more so
today's workout
really worked on your endurance
your as well as your power and that's
what we want in order to burn fat burn
lots of calories and also to build your
endurance strength i hope you enjoyed
today's challenge and be sure to repeat
this challenge every alternate days
and if you enjoyed this video do give
this video a thumbs up
like this video share this video on and
also hit the subscribe button and i will
see you in my next challenge if you want
a challenge then let me know in the
comments below and give me a suggestion
as well all the best